hey folks I'm Lucy and welcome to
another episode of good news gaming the
show that highlights all the good and
fun stuff from the week in games just
like this perfect recreation of the
distracted boyfriend meme in the good
news this week someone managed to hit
100 percent of the notes on through the
fire and flames on Guitar Hero on expert
with the song at 165 percent speed I
don't think I could get through this
song on medium even at the height of my
Guitar Hero days so this video from gh
addict is frankly amazing his world
record was even recognized by one of the
games developers Chris Vance who
commented on the YouTube video 14 years
ago when I charted this song we almost
cut it from the game because I was the
only person who could beat it for the
first month or two we had to make it the
credit song you couldn't fail because no
way in hell we could put it in the main
progression and expect players to beat
the game fast forward to now and y'all
keep blowing my mind it's honestly
humbling to see all this awesome love
and enjoyment put into our hard work
congratulations on the new world record
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's the world record I'm gonna
piss a fantastic new initiative from the
UK games industry is providing free
video games to frontline NHS workers by
heading to the website that I'll link
down below and entering that NHS email
address they can claim a free game from
the likes of Zam Xbox game studios Sega
Bungie Deep Silver and more one of the
organizers Chris Kelly until GameSpot
you and I know how cathartic gaming can
be and how it can provide some
much-needed escapism it will be
unrealistic to say that a free game can
completely wipe those thoughts from
their heads but I hope they can at least
distract them for long enough to help
them unwind between shifts and be in a
happier place for a while
kudos to all the game studios and
developers who are taking part but most
of all a huge thank you to everyone
who's working in the healthcare service
and anyone who's helping provide covert
relief in this weird time and so I'm
glad there are these initiatives that
are helping them unwind a little bit I
love watching people make things it's
really comforting to me in a weird way
it's like ASMR so that explains why I
spent 20 minutes during a workday
watching this guy make a Super Nintendo
fishtank that actually works
so many people sent this to me last week
and I'm so sorry we didn't include it in
the last show but it happened just after
we'd already filmed them editing but
Elijah Wood sliding into people's DMS
for a wholesome reason just to sell his
turnips on Animal Crossing or so sweet
and the thing that really got me wasn't
that it was just oh you know celebrity
playing games they're really just like
us it was the fact that when he went to
the fans Island he was so polite he was
saying things like yo island is so
beautiful and may I pick some fruit it
really warmed my heart and as a lifelong
Lord of the Rings fan couldn't have
asked for anything more wholesome the
Center for computing history back in the
UK has along with many other places had
to close its doors during social
isolation they have an incredible
collection of computers and of course
video games from throughout history and
so while it's super sad that people
won't be able to go there and get
hands-on with them there is a way you
can take a look they've built a replica
of the museum inside Animal Crossing new
leaf so you can go tour it if you'd like
to and if you'd like to support the
museum while it's closed check the
description for a link to that Just
Giving page they have a really
incredible collection there and they do
a lot of events with schoolchildren to
try and educate them about computing
history so very worthwhile cause a
silver lining of isolation I guess if
you can call it that is the people are
getting really really creative with
their memes troy was an okay movie I
remember enjoying it at the time but the
Internet has improved it a thousandfold
by adding Age of Empires music and sound
effects to it seriously I don't know how
they thought of this but
[Music]
as we have weird memes there's a great
new Twitter account well relatively new
Twitter account chords a huge Nintendo
DS which does what it says on the tin
really it just it's just photoshopped
pictures of celebrities and game
developers with comically sized Nintendo
DS's
I really liked the one with Gabe Newell
he has a TS the size of a laptop it's
great it's such a good Turk I know that
was that giant baby that went viral on
Twitter and Tech Talk last week and
loads of people were talking about it
but honestly I think that this is the
giant baby we should all be talking
about this carrier that makes like any
kid that's inside look like fat man from
Metal Gear Solid 2 laughs and grow fat
young one for Nate has been crushing it
lately last weekend they had that unreal
Travis Scott concert show experience
thing I don't really know what to call
it but it was really incredible and
showed kind of the power of what video
games can be and it looks like they have
something cool in the works called party
Royale for tonight data miner Lucas 7
Yoshi uncovered a brand new map which is
believed to be part of the new in
limited time mode that'll bring people
together to just hang out instead of
jerking it out over who's gonna get that
victory royale epic confirm the modes
existence to polygon saying welcome to
the party
leave your weapons and mats behind and
hang out with friends play games affect
your skydive and more the party's just
getting started something you might not
know about me is that I'm actually quite
big tennis fan when I was younger I was
lucky enough with my school to actually
go to Wimbledon and I got to see one of
my idols play Serena Williams and
obviously I was kind of a bit sad that
Wimbledon was canceled this year it's
understandable but you know she's
incredible and I love watching her play
so very excited about this Knicks news
story because it looks like we can watch
her play this Sunday May 3rd 7
not playing actual tennis playing Mario
Tennis faces alongside Serena and her
sister Venus Williams they'll be other
famous tennis pros like Sharapova and
the stay-at-home slam will also feature
celebrities like Gigi Hadid and seal
let's just hope he doesn't get eaten by
wolves as a pop star never something I'm
stopping reference one of the greatest
and funniest movies ever made just trust
me on that
anyway the stay-at-home slam is this
Sunday May 3rd I'm gonna be tuning in
let me know if you do too and finally an
announcement from GameSpot so that's a
bit better but this is a cool thing that
we're doing we were just as sad as I'm
sure a lot of you were that III was
cancelled this year so this summer we're
holding a huge weeks-long digital event
to try and help fill that void so we're
gonna obviously be covering all the big
announcements over the summer working
with CD Projekt RED Bethesda Square Enix
2k and tons more to bring you all the
latest game announcements interviews
with developers etc but we're also going
to be raising money for kovat relief so
on the one hand we have kind of digital
III and then on the other hand we're
gonna do tons of streams with your
favorite streamers youtubers games
industry folks and developers so that's
gonna be really cool and all the
proceeds will be going to what's Coen
relief if you would like to list some
people you'd love to see featured
because I'm helping doing the booking
and the programming let me know either
put them in the comments below
come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games or come join us on the
discord we were talking about it a lot
in there we've had some great
suggestions and people I'm reaching out
to that have been suggested from our
community DMA for an invite and I hope
to see you in there we're really excited
about what we've got coming this summer
and we hope you are too and we would
love to have you play a part so join the
discord get involved and play for all
comes this
that's all we've got time for this week
see you next time
[Music]